[Music]
thank you
J.R.R Tolkien begins his essay on
fairies stories understandably enough
with the question what is a fairy story
and he's going to spend a good bit of
the first part of the piece trying to
disentangle what fairy stories in let's
call it a proper sense are from what
other people in a more loose even sloppy
terminology will call fairy stories so
that he can zero in on what is genuinely
essential and that's going to allow him
to throw away or expurgate some of the
candidates for Fairy stories and he
begins as we often should by saying
don't go to the dictionary because that
is not actually going to help you it's a
knee-jerk reaction that many people have
to think oh if I have to figure out what
the meaning of a word is I'd better go
to the diction and that'll tell me
exactly what it is it'll give me the
essence of the thing and Tolkien says in
this case you will turn to the Oxford
English Dictionary in vain and so you
know it's not just any dictionary it's
the Oxford English Dictionary and why he
says well it contains no reference to
the combination fairy story and is
unhelpful on the subject of fairies
generally in the supplement fairy tale
as recorded since the year 1750 and then
he gives a you know tripartite
definition of this its leading sense is
said to be a a tale about fairies or
generally a fairy Legend with developed
senses be an unreal or incredible story
and see a falsehood and then Tolkien
says B and C are so broad that this
could not possibly help us to understand
what a fairy fairy story is you know any
falsehood can be a fairy story so he
says the first sense though is too
narrow
not too narrow for an essay it's wide
enough for many books but too narrow to
cover actual usage and then he says okay
if we look at the definition of fairies
that's being given there maybe that'll
help us right and there's three elements
to this as well he says supernatural
beings of diminutive size and popular
beliefs supposed to possess magical
powers and have great influence for good
or evil over the Affairs of men and then
he says all right let's think about this
Supernatural yeah kind of he says
Supernatural is a dangerous and
difficult word in any of its senses but
to fairies it can hardly be applied
unless super is taken merely as a
superlative prefix so saying that you
know there in some sense greater right
and it gives this great uh little line a
set of lines here oh see you ye not ya
narrow road so thick beset with thorns
and Briars that is the path of
righteousness though after it but few
inquires ncu not John braid braid road
that lies across the Lily 11 that is the
path of wickedness
though some call it the road to heaven
so tooth so far right and see you not
Yan Bonnie Road that whines about John
ferny Bry that is the road to Fair elf
land where thou and I this night
Mountain guy
so you know Supernatural yes but not
within the framework of say the
Christian conception of the supernatural
what about diminutive he says well this
is indeed a notion that's quite common
in Modern Times And he says of old there
were indeed some inhabitants of fairy
that were small but smallness was not
characteristic of the people as a whole
that's more a function of modern
storytelling and the need to make
fairies tiny and delicate and stuff like
that and uh you know he says that's
really not the case in a lot of fairy
stories
um what about being powerful well you
know it it is something that comes up
quite a bit right and they do have
some degree of influence on the fates of
human beings if human beings are
involved with them
Tolkien is going to say
people have gotten this kind of
backwards they're trying to Define
fairies stories by referencing fairies
kind of beings right
really what they should be referencing
is something different
fairy a land a realm and so he says
fairy is a noun more or less equivalent
to elf is a relatively modern word right
and then he talks about the folk of
fairy meaning this this land and he says
that
[Music]
um
here we go
the trouble with the real folk of fairy
is they do not always look like what
they are they put on the pride and
Beauty we would feign where ourselves at
least part of the magic they wield for
the good of evil a good or evil of man
is the power to play on the desires of
his body and his heart and he says
stories about fairies too narrow but
stories about fairy the land now we're
on to something he says
um I've digressed from my proper theme
fairy stories I said the sense stories
about fairies was too narrow it's too
narrow even if we reject the diminutive
size for Fairy stories are not a normal
English usage stories about fairies or
else but stories about fairy that is
fairy the realm or state in which
fairies have their beings
and what other kinds of beings are there
he says it contains many things besides
elves and phase and besides dwarves
which is trolls Giants or dragons it
holds the Seas the Sun the moon the sky
and the Earth and all things that are in
it tree and bird water and stone wine
and bread and ourselves mortal men when
we are enchanted
so the definition of fairy's story is
really going to depend on the nature of
this land of fairy the what he calls the
perilous realm itself and the air that
blows in that country now is that
susceptible of definition Tolkien says
no you cannot Define this land and he
says I'm not even going to describe it
directly it cannot be done fairy cannot
be caught in and out of words for it is
one of its qualities to be Indescribable
though not imperceptible it has many
elements but analysis will not
necessarily discover the secret of the
whole it can be described and it must be
described in fact in narratives
but we can't constrain it through these
nets of words he's saying and he goes
out and talks about the purposes of
fairy tales in a very interesting way
before that he says I will say that's a
fairy story is one which touches on or
uses fairy and then he brings in
purposes whatever its own main purpose
may be and he gives four this is not a
necessarily exclusive or exhaustive list
satire Adventure morality or fantasy
he also says that fairy may be most
nearly translated by Magic
but its magic is of a peculiar mood and
power at the furthest pull from the
vulgar devices of the laborious
scientific magician and he gives us a
Proviso as well if there is any satire
present in the tail one thing must not
be made fun of the magic itself that
must in the series story be taken
seriously and either laughed at nor
explained away and he gives sergoane and
the Green Knight as a prime example of
that so there's multiple
possible motives for the narratives that
comprise fairy tales it does involve
magic and a little bit later he's going
to tell us something important about the
magic that is rather determinative of
fairy tales
he says the magic of fairy is not an end
in itself its virtue is in its
operations among these are the
satisfaction of certain primordial human
desires really basic things that we we
all experience even if we're not fully
conscious of and what are some examples
to survey the depths of space and time
to to explore to find out right our
human curiosity another he says is to
hold communion with other living things
right and so a story that involves these
he says approaches fairy stories and
genuine fairy stories do involve these
the other thing that he says that helps
us wrap our head around what a fairy
tale is
he says it's essential to a genuine
fairy story
that it should be presented as true and
he uses true in quotes or brackets there
the meaning of true in this connection
he says I'll consider later on but the
fairy story cannot tolerate any frame or
Machinery suggesting that the whole
story in which they occur is just a
figment or Illusion it has to on some
level be presented as a object of belief
albeit what Tolkien will call secondary
belief in this
he also engages in what he is willing to
label as expurgations he is throwing out
certain things as not being fairy
stories even though some people would
call them that and so one of the types
that he he says
um is uh you know Travelers tales that
feature little people he says
um
consider a voyage to Lilliput which is
in the Blue Fairy book I will say this
it is not a fairy story neither as its
author made it nor as it here appears
condensed by Miss May Kendall it has no
business in this place why
because the fact that lilliputians are
tiny by comparison to you know say
Gulliver or somebody like that
doesn't make them you know inhabitants
of the realm of fairy and he says
smallness is in fairy as in our world
only an accident pygmies are no nearer
to fairies than our patagonians I do not
rule this story out because it's
satirical intent I rule it out because
the vehicle of the satire belongs to the
class of Travelers Tales which may
include many Marvels
but are not for that
fairy tales because they're not about
Fairy Land they're about other lands
right so we can eliminate those and then
going to the issue of Truth he says I
would rule out any story that uses the
Machinery of dream or the dreaming of
actual human sleep to explain the
apparent occurrence of its Marvels at
the least even if the reported dream was
in other respects in itself a fairy
story I would condemn the whole as
Gravely defective it is a good picture
in a disfiguring frame and he says it's
not that dream is not connected at all
with fairy but it's something different
right uh he says in dreams strange
powers of the Mind may be unlocked in
them a man-made for a space wheel the
power of fairy
a real dream may indeed sometimes be a
fairy story of almost Elvish ease and
skill while it is being dreamed
but you wake up from the dream and so
you know and then you say oh it was just
a dream as we do you know it's become
kind of a Trope in uh a lot of uh uh
narratives that we have ourselves so
those are not fairy tales and then
finally he's going to rule out one other
kind
um
and again he says it's not because I
don't like it
pure Beast Fable right all these stories
about you know whatever monkeys or
sharks or The Three Little Pigs perhaps
or all these sorts of things these are
actually Beast or animal fables right
and he says they have a connection with
fairy stories beasts and birds and other
creatures often talk like human beings
and fairy stories right and they perhaps
stem from one of the basic Primal
desires the desire to hold communion
with other living things but the speech
of beasts and the Beast Fable has
developed into a separate branch has
little reference to that desire and
often wholly forgets it right
so you know he says in stories in which
no human being is concerned or in which
the animals are the heroes and heroines
and men and women if they appear a mere
adjuncts above all those in which the
animal form is only a mask upon a human
face
in these we have the Beast Fable and not
a fairy story whether it be rainard the
fox or the nuns priest tale or brayer
rabbit or merely The Three Little Pigs
and he says there are some borderline
cases like the stories of Beatrix Potter
lying near the borders of fairy but
outside of it their nearness is due
largely to their strong moral elements
right so they're sort of allegorical and
so these are not uh in his view fairy
tales either and this gives us a good
sense of if not a definition at least
what we can count as fairy tales and
what falls out of their purview even
though people may use that term for them
rather imprecisely